[Música]
costa rica- las elecciones
presidenciales mañana domingo con 25
candidatos desde ya les contábamos que m
son los aspirantes más opcionados y cuál
es el panorama político del país
día de campaña presidencial para la
extrema derecha en francia los
candidatos más independiente se disputan
los votos de los más conservadores y
compiten con discursos contra el islam y
los migrantes
eeuu se vio parte de las 3000 tropas que
desplegar en polonia en medio de las
tensiones entre rusia y ucrania
el grupo de altos oficiales hace parte
del refuerzo que la otan tiene para
prepararse ante un eventual ataque de
los co
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y
comenzamos esta emisión en costa rica
porque mañana 6 de febrero ese país
elegirá al próximo gobierno en medio de
un récord y es que en estas elecciones
generales hay 25 aspirantes una cifra
que no se veía desde 1930 sin embargo
tres de los candidatos concentran casi
el 50% de la intención de voto según las
últimas encuestas
previamente conversamos con lina
barrantes presidenta de la firma crisis
y estrategias ella nos explicó cuál es
el tema que mueve esta campaña
yo creo que los problemas principales
que tenemos
giran alrededor de la crisis económica
y desempleo producto de la crisis
sanitaria crisis sanitaria que ha sido
muy bien manejada porque nuestro sistema
de salud tuvo la fuerza de hacerle
frente como no ha pasado en países
desarrollados y con mucho dinero sin
embargo aquí sí pudimos hacerle frente
nuestros hospitales no han colapsado
tenemos un gran porcentaje de la
población vacunada pero la parte de las
medidas que se tomaron tuvieron que ver
con cierres no tan drásticos como en
europa pero sí siempre es importante la
gente dejó de circular mucho y eso
afectó terriblemente
a la informalidad
y la informalidad
desgraciadamente es una cantidad enorme
de gente en este país
miles de manifestantes y activistas del
movimiento black life smarter se tomaron
las calles de una veintena de ciudades
en brasil su objetivo es denunciar la
violencia racista tras el asesinato de
un refugiado congoleño llamado moix
kagamé el homicidio ocurrió luego de una
disputa en la que se exigía el pago de
su salario marina sardiña tiene los
detalles
exigiendo justicia y bajo el lema dejen
de matar negros miles de personas
salieron a las calles de varias ciudades
brasileñas en rechazo al asesinato del
joven congoleño moix cava anpe que murió
hace menos de dos semanas tras recibir
una paliza
hay mucha injusticia porque el trabajo
que hacía morir el dinero que sacaba de
aquí era para ayudar a su familia el
joven de 24 años dejó su país natal hace
8 yendo de la violencia pues trabajaba
en un bar de río de janeiro donde fue
brutalmente asesinado por tres hombres
cuando pedía el pago pendiente de dos
días de trabajo unos 37 dólares los
asesinos están ahora en custodia
policial felizmente los brazos de una
lamentable mente un brazo existe un
racismo estructural
el racismo que nosotros como pueblo
negro experimentamos todos los días con
miedo de morir de salir de casa y no
volver de casa y no vota para los
manifestantes la violencia contra la
población afro es endémica en brasil
como lo demuestran también las altas
tasas de brutalidad policial en río el
86 por ciento de los fallecidos en
operativos policiales eran negros
el estado brasileño racista es un estado
nazi es un estado homofóbico y xenófobo
tiene que parar
acaba otro de los pedidos de los
activistas afros presentes en la
manifestación fue la destitución del
presidente de ultraderecha yair
bolsonaro ha sido hacer comentarios
racistas contra cualquier minoría hoy
fue un día de campaña para la extrema
derecha en francia tanto ma jin lepe en
como eric se me defendieron sus visiones
en contra de la inmigración y del islam
desde la ciudad de gameplay hizo su
primer gran mitin e intentó ganar
algunos adeptos tras los golpes que ha
recibido su campaña por las renuncias de
parte de su equipo para apoyar hace
mucho mientras tanto este
ultraderechista realizó su evento el
mismo día en lille en el norte de
francia y allí atacó lo que llamo la
islamización del país
la terrible verdad lo que sabemos lo que
según las encuestas preocupa el 67 por
ciento de los franceses es que francia
se está islamizando a toda velocidad
y vio al ya hay un vínculo evidente
entre la explosión de la inseguridad y
estas oleadas de inmigración que estamos
sufriendo con univision para back
coaching esta inmigración incontrolada
está convirtiendo nuestras calles
nuestros barrios nuestras ciudades en
zonas no francesa un down house la otan
refuerza sus tropas cerca de rusia en
medio y las tensiones de moscú y kiev es
que ya llegó a polonia un grupo de altos
oficiales de las fuerzas armadas de eeuu
que hacen parte de los 3.000 efectivos
que estarán allí mientras tanto rusia y
ucrania están realizando ejercicios
militares
comenzó el refuerzo oriental de la otan
esta mañana una avioneta aterrizó en el
sur de polonia con un grupo de altos
mandos militares estadounidenses el
arribo de los oficiales no identificados
forma parte del contingente de 3.000
soldados pertenecientes a la 82 brigada
aerotransportada de los eeuu que
permanecerán temporalmente en la nación
europea por orden del presidente joe
biden comienza pagando por chips este
apoyo que nos llega es también un signo
de solidaridad aliada y muestra de que
juntos somos más fuertes podemos confiar
unos en otros cerca de allí se preparan
las condiciones logísticas para el
alojamiento de los efectivos quienes
están arribando desde el viernes en la
noche
la presencia estadounidense divide la
opinión de los residentes en la zona
en general estoy en contra de que
polonia interfiera en los asuntos de
ucrania todo es humo y espejos es todo
obrero creo que es una buena medida creo
que todavía no hay suficientes tropas y
debemos esforzarnos por reunir más en
este contexto las maniobras militares no
cesan este sábado la flota del pacífico
rusa realizó ejercicios en el estrecho
de la perú próximo al mar de japón al
tiempo que dos bombarderos estratégicos
sobrevolaron belarús
mientras la guardia nacional de ucrania
desarrolló maniobras entre los edificios
abandonados de las zonas de exclusión de
chernóbil cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa y a poco más de 130
kilómetros de kiev la capital de ucrania
el gobierno de marruecos abrirá las
fronteras a partir del 7 de febrero
después de haberla cerrado durante casi
dos años a causa de la pandemia uno de
los sectores más golpeados es el turismo
en marrakech casi la mitad de los
hoteles y la mayoría de los
establecimientos turísticos cerraron
desde hace tiempo nuestra corresponsal
sofía catalana nos cuenta la historia
en marrakech capital turístico de
marruecos y las protestas han estado a
la orden del día en el último mes en las
fronteras cerraron hace casi dos años se
había convertido en una crisis para los
trabajadores del turismo y ante la
presión el gobierno ha anunciado la
reapertura inminente del país
nos abren la frontera el 7 de febrero y
es una gran noticia para todos pero
vamos a continuar nuestra lucha porque
no queremos que vuelva a cerrar no bajes
udine el hadjuk una tiene una farmacia
en la medina ha estado al frente de las
protestas y es muy activa en el barrio
explica que los vecinos ya no tienen
dinero ni para medicinas
la gente está enferma pero no tiene ni
para medicina desde el bazar trabaja con
el taxista con el transportista con el
de la tienda de teléfonos con el
vendedor destruimos uno depende del otro
fernández casi el 50% de los hoteles y
centenares de establecimientos de todo
tipo llevan mucho tiempo cerrados
artesanos comerciantes artistas dos años
parados la mayoría del estado
solo espero que no vuelvan a cerrar que
en dos o tres meses no vuelvan a cerrar
estamos hartos de tanto cerrar de verdad
hermana no tengo para comer si alguien
viene le vendo artículos de 2010 james
180 dólares por 500 grit james 45
dólares adivino sus compañeros han
montado un campo de protesta frente al
hotel donde trabajaban en plena pandemia
los dueños cerraron y dejaron a la
plantilla sin indemnización
hacemos esto por los derechos que se nos
vulneran nuestro derecho a volver al
trabajo o recibir nuestra administración
quizás con la reapertura el turismo la
situación para el vídeo y sus compañeros
cambien por ahora la famosa plaza ya me
alucina sigue vacía y es un reflejo de
la agonía que atraviesa más rápido
y terminamos con una noticia del arte
porque el tapiz de guernica de pablo
picasso volvió a decorar la entrada de
la sede principal de naciones unidas en
nueva york esta pieza estuvo allí desde
1984 a manera de préstamo pero en
febrero de 2021 su dueño original un
miembro de la familia rockefeller lo
hizo retirar para recuperarlo ahora la
multimillonaria familia le devolvió la
custodia a la onu de este tapiz esta no
es la obra original de pablo picasso
pues la pintura del artista español está
en el museo reina sofía en madrid
y hasta aquí nuestra emisión de noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
la señal de france 24
[Música]